nochmal die ja spezialeinheiten der jva
die den attentäter reinbringen
wir sehen die maskierten männer mit
ihren taktischen schutzwesten
einige tragen auch pistolen im
gerichtssaal ja und der attentäter
selbst mit einer corona maske schwarze
jacke wir haben vorhin noch gesehen dass
er selbst eine schutzweste getragen hat
die haben sie ihm offenbar für den
eigentlichen gerichtssaal ausgezogen und
da sitzt er jetzt die hände noch
gefestigt die füße auch gefesselt das
wissen wir
neben seinen verteidigern ja und genießt
die show genießt die kameras jetzt haben
sehen wir die handfesseln du hast gesagt
die werden ihnen im laufe des prozesses
dann noch abgenommen gefesselt an den
füßen bleibt er trotzdem hat das was mit
seinem fluchtversuch zu tun ist das
immer so nein das hat mit seinem
fluchtversuch das hat mit seinem typ
täter zu tun der er einfach ist der
sozusagen die die beamten wollen da auf
absolute nummer sicher gehen
deswegen stehen diese mindestens zwei
von dieser spezialeinheit bei dieser
beamten immer direkt neben ihm die füße
bleiben gefesselt und wir haben auch
gehört dass die verhandlungen
unterbrochen wird das sozusagen für ihn
ein spezieller verfahren gebaut wurde in
dem er dann untergebracht verwahrt wird
und wenn es weitergeht in der
verhandlung wieder rausgeholt wird jetzt
in den ersten bildern die uns erreicht
haben scheint er relativ ruhig vorher
hatte man ja die sorge muss man fast
sagen dass er jetzt diesen prozess nutzt
als show für sich selber es bleibt das
dann wahrscheinlich jetzt so oder kann
noch immer was kommen ich schätze dass
ein
also wir alle haben an an der spree
gedacht der damals nach seinem
fürchterlichen anschlag den prozess
genutzt hat beim ersten tag der
verhandlung ja versucht hat den
hitlergruß zu zeigen und alle haben sich
gefreut passiert hier heute so was auch
das scheint bis jetzt so nicht passiert
zu sein
jetzt muss man sagen das ist der moment
nach mal so ein zwei minuten wo die
kameras rausgebracht werden ab jetzt
sozusagen läuft die eigentliche
verhandlung und was jetzt natürlich dort
passiert ob er die verhandlung stört ob
er einen ruf ob er aufspringt das wissen
wir jetzt alles noch nicht das wird sich
in den nächsten minuten und stunden und
dann auch in den nächsten wochen so
lange wir die verhandlung dauert eben
zeigen ja der prozess findet in
magdeburg statt der saal wurde in den
letzten monaten extra um
aber dafür um die höchste
sicherheitsstufe zu haben der ganze
prozess natürlich unter extremen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen und wenn auch
bilder heute von seiner ankunft in
magdeburg denn tatsächlich war diese
auch ziemlich speziell muss man sagen
hier wurde mit einem helikopter abgeholt
auch dafür wollen uns die bilder nochmal
angucken und sag uns warum das ganze und
was ist auch das besondere an dieser
ankunft ja sind eben bilder wie man sie
von top-terroristen kennt so werden
islamistische attentäter oder eben der
attentäter von der synagoge auf halle
zum gericht gebracht
man will absolut sichergehen dass dort
nichts passieren kann es mit einem
eurocopter hubschrauber der polizei in
die nähe gebracht worden dort haben dann
wir haben es angesprochen
dieser besondere sicherheitsdienst im
justizvollzug diese spezialgruppe auf
ihn gewartet die männer alle gekleidet
angezogen wie eine spezialeinheit
schwarze overalls schwarze masken
pistolen schusssichere westen er selbst
hat auch einige tragen mann wollte
offenbar sichergehen dass auch ihm
nichts passieren kann dass hier eine
vernünftige verhandlung stattfinden kann
nicht noch eine panne stattfinden und
dann ist er in einen längeren größeren
polizeikonvoi gekommen
und die haben ihn zum gerichtsgebäude
gebracht dort ist jetzt angekommen auch
die weder haben wir gerade gesehen sind
wirklich spektakuläre bilder von einer
verhandlung auf die ganz europa jetzt
legt denn der anschlag in halle ist uns
natürlich allen und gedächtnis geblieben
er steht jetzt wegen zweifachen mord und
mehrfachen versuchten mord vor gericht
kannst du uns auch noch einmal
zusammenfassen wie wie diese attacke
diese der terroranschlag abgelaufen ist
also wir wissen über den täter das ja
ein einzelgänger war und zwar seit
seiner jugend keine freunde keine
freundinnen in seiner zeit im wehrdienst
ist ja verspottet worden von den anderen
kameraden er hat die uni abgebrochen und
hat sich dann irgendwann ins internet
gerettet dort weiter radikalisiert am
gleichgesinnte womöglich gefunden mit
den kommuniziert und dann eben im laufe
der zeit ein anschlagsplan entwickelt er
hat angefangen mit der synagoge in halle
die wollte er stürmen wollte ein blutbad
anrichten das hat er so klar gesagt an
dort war der jom kippur gottesdienst 68
leute etwa anderen frauen kinder alte
babys und da wollte er rein die wollte
er am morgen
am ende hat eine holztür das verhindert
kein wachdienst keine polizei einfach
nur eine schlichte holztür wenn man die
einmal gesehen hat dann kann man da wird
man da sprachlos aber diese holztür hat
gehalten und verhindert dass er dort
rein kam er hat dann geflucht er hat die
tat in live im internet gezeigt und hat
sich gesagt gut dann suche ich mir das
nächstbeste ziel und das war in seiner
kranken ideologie eine dönerbude um die
ecke
dort ist er eingerannt am hat weiter um
sich geschossen und hat während des
attentats zwei deutsche getötet eine
frau die passantin war und ein junger
mann der döner in der dönerbude gegessen
hat er an bild